all right let's keep going today so much
to uh to pack into today's program we're
not going to spend a lot of time on this
last night not only did Sean Hannity go
after me and direct the right wing
contrived hate mob against me he also
aired another portion of his interview
with the failed former president Donald
Trump and this is this is a short clip
it's really just the epitome of what
I've been telling you for years Trump
loves dictators Trump is impressed by
dictators Trump thinks dictators are big
strong guys and the entire thing and
Sean Hannity did this thing which I mean
it's just a complete and total backfire
it's really unbelievable where he lists
different dictators and authoritarians
to Trump and says tell me the first
thing that comes to mind and with every
single one of them what comes to mind is
how great Trump gets along with them
it's you know if if seven years ago I
had told you we're gonna have a former
president who when asked about dictators
and authoritarian strongman just goes I
got along really well I don't know got
along really well I don't know you
wouldn't have believed it but that's
where we are look at this orange
nightmare right
I'm going to give names and give me
quick
short sentence of narratives by the way
Trump just so sweaty eyes almost swollen
shut never clear why what why is it so
hot I don't know if it comes to your
mind Putin
well I'm gonna have to go a little short
but uh I got along with them great uh
I've been president he would have been
much better off because he wouldn't have
gone into Ukraine yeah the The Reason by
the way this entire thing they keep
repeating
it
why why did Putin wait for Joe Biden to
go into Ukraine
Putin had every reason to think that he
wouldn't have to invade in order to get
more territory with Trump as president
if Trump gets another four years Putin
can probably get away with taking more
land in other ways that doesn't require
what he is now doing it's such a
laughable talking boy okay so there's
Putin we're gonna keep going but
ultimately he's going to take over all
of Ukraine we know right especially if
you have a say chi uh a man I got along
again I got along with him great until
code came in we would have been able to
work together very well I got I made an
unbelievable deal for our farmers and
manufacturers where China was giving us
50 billion dollars a year to our farmers
and our manufacturers got along great
with she
sorry and I stepped over that he says
Kim Jong-un he has 50 billion dollars a
year to our farmers and our
manufacturers
uh again got along with them great
people don't want to hear that a lot of
people say that's terrible to get along
with them great when somebody has
nuclear weapons that can blow up the
world it's nice to get along I get along
with them great so listen there are two
sides to this okay let me I I really
want to be this is such a microcosm of
the entire Trump Fiasco on foreign
policy that we have to do both sides
there's the simple side okay the simple
side is
Trump is impressed by authoritarians
it's not just Putin and she and Kim
Jong-un
who he believes everything they say and
you know we'll get to that it's also
erdogan
it's Orban
it's bolsonaro it's okay oh it's all of
them part of it is Trump is just
impressed with them constitutionally
just who they are what they represent
how they behave Trump is in some cases
jealous of them that they have Trump
perceives them to have a gravitas that
he doesn't have but would like to so
there's that side of it but there's
another side of it that's important as
well
it's easy to get along with people who
don't see you as a threat in any way
most of those leaders saw Trump for the
bumbling buffoon that he was and when
you're seen that way there's no reason
to have conflict or a tense relationship
or disagreements or whatever the case
may be because they don't take you
seriously enough to see you as a threat
you're you're not credible enough you're
not Alpha enough to use their version of
what they are talking right
why would you have trouble getting along
with someone who sees you as a doofus
you wouldn't and that's the other side
of it now we can apply this really
specifically for example with Kim
Jong-un
going back decades
in general
it's not that the North Korean leader
wasn't willing to meet with an American
president it's that the American
Presidents didn't see the point of
meeting with the North Korean leaders
without some preconditions why when you
consider the status difference between
an American president and a North Korean
dictator that leads the country the
North Korean dictator is always willing
to get the photo op to get the
propaganda value of meeting with an
American president to then show their uh
population look we're on the world stage
and we told that President and blah blah
blah
it's not difficult to get a meeting with
a North Korean leader if you're an
American president Trump was so clueless
that when he convinced Kim Jong-un to
meet with him he acted like it was an
accomplishment this is why he gets along
with these dictators because they see
Trump they go wow this guy doesn't even
understand why it is that normally they
wouldn't even meet with me at the
meeting
Kim Jong-un made the same promises to
Trump that every North Korean leader has
made in the past to American Presidents
which they have no intentions of keeping
will demilitarize this and we'll do that
and we'll provide this other thing Trump
doesn't know anything so Trump thinks
look at all of these great promises I
got these are the same promises that
they've been making for decades they
will do 10 of it in order to get food
Aid and then ignore the other 90 it's
not an accomplishment so again it's easy
to get along with people who are just
walking all over you in every way
because you're so clueless but anyway so
the whole point of it is a very sweaty
very swollen Trump
in this interview able to say nothing
other than I got along with these guys
really well of course you did one of our
continued sponsors is ground news an app
and website that Aggregates local and
international news sources to show you
how breaking news is being reported
around the world it has become a go-to
resource for me right now I'm looking at
a story about residents in Ohio
reporting medical symptoms after the
train derailment ground news shows the
headline from The Washington Post owned
by Jeff Bezos says East Palestine
residents should look to agent orange
victims the headline from The Epic Times
a radical right-wing Outlet says Federal
officials enter 500 East Palestine homes
after toxic train crash I also like that
you can sort things by factuality
location and bias check out ground news
for free at Ground dot News slash Pacman
if you find ground news as useful as I
do subscribe for unlimited access the
link is down below